you would think that the most expensive
best iPhone is the one with the best
battery life right
nope this here is the new iPhone 14 plus
it's basically just the iPhone 14 but
bigger so the mini sized iPhone is dead
after two years and they've replaced it
with this plus size version which means
a bigger screen and a bigger battery I
will say it is a bit lighter than you'd
probably expect that aluminum makes this
big phone actually lighter than the
smaller Pro with its stainless steel but
there's really not that much else
interesting here except that when Apple
announced it on stage they said that it
would be the best battery life ever in
an iPhone and then they just moved on I
guess that does make sense though right
it's the same size as the iPhone 14 pro
Max same battery size roughly but with a
dimmer 60 hertz display so I guess yeah
it should last longer but is it actually
substantially longer see when you get to
Apple's website the iPhone 14 pro Max is
the one listed at 29 hours of video
playback Which is higher than this 14
plus which is listed at 26 hours but
then again just for audio playback the
plus will do a hundred hours for the
first time which is more than the pro
Max which is just 95 hours super useful
for those of us doing five straight
hours of audio playback in airplane mode
right but no that this is the first
point I wanted to make in this video
which is that in the smartphone World
these days the benchmarks are less and
less relevant than ever and I almost
don't even pay attention to them anymore
unlike back in the day when they used to
be really important like years ago new
phones would come out and they would
have huge year-over-year performance
gains which was exciting but mostly
because they would actually like unlock
new things that you could do with your
phone things like shooting 4K video for
the first time or playing HD games or
taking HDR photos with a bunch of
different exposures so that big jump in
raw performance year over year meant
before the jump you couldn't do a thing
and then after the jump you crushed a
threshold and now you could which was
sweet but smartphones are so evolved and
so complete nowadays that basically
every smartphone can do all the
fundamental things very well it's more
around the edges that they're starting
to optimize for certain tasks certain
things so yes the overall power and the
geekbench score still does go up a
little bit year over year every year but
that doesn't really mean nearly as much
as it used to it doesn't really mean
anything significant other than maybe a
few more frames per second in a game or
launching an app slightly faster Plus in
this one's case it's the same chip as
last year so it means almost nothing but
what's really happening now is companies
are developing their own silicon with
special sections of their system on a
chip designed to accelerate certain
functions that they think will be a
priority for their users so if Apple you
know the a series chips and the iPhones
means big performance cores small
efficiency cores but then a bunch of
other stuff things like a prores
accelerator for faster video encoding
there is a neural engine for optimizing
machine learning tasks and there's a
special image signal processor for
fusing to together different exposures
into a photo very quickly and a display
engine that helps smoothly run those
animations for the Pro phone on the
dynamic island with Google you've got
the new tensor chip in their pixel
phones again big cores small cores but
then dedicated pieces for machine
learning for their Crazy Fast speech to
text there's an image signal processor
for HDR plus and then more and more some
apple flagships even though they haven't
gotten to designing their own silicon
entirely are still adding things like a
specialized ISP to the find X5 Pro for
processing photos the way they want to
much faster and now it's even starting
to apply to all types of other devices
we already know about Apple silicon Max
you know the M1 chip having a prores
accelerator because that's important to
a lot of people using Pro Max also the
steam deck has a custom Apu that lets it
hit certain frame rates in lower power
States basically the point is these
companies are now adding focused pieces
of compute Hardware when they design
products based on what they think is a
priority to their users and accelerate
those those things dramatically and
those pieces make a bigger difference
than any Benchmark will show like here
here's this is a good analogy I like a
good comparison so let's say you need a
vehicle for the fastest time around a
track and you get to choose between
vehicle a and vehicle B all you get to
choose from is benchmarks so the
benchmarks for vehicle a is it did a 0
to 60 in 3.5 seconds it got on a Dyno
and measured 502 horsepower and 339
pound-feet of torque then vehicle B did
the 0 to 60 in three seconds flat it
measured 835 horsepower and 908
pound-feet of torque so okay just based
on those numbers a sensible person would
probably lean towards picking vehicle B
that would mean you just picked the
rivion r1t a very fast pickup truck but
you just picked that over the 2018
Porsche 911 GT3 one of the best track
cars ever made that's how I feel about
relying on basic General benchmarks
these days like the benchmarks tell one
story about the general overall
capability but you still should be
picking based on the specific features
and things you want to do like you want
to carry around lots of huge things get
the one with the huge trunk do you want
to make quick turns at high speeds get
the one with the arrow pieces do you
want to take lots of pictures and videos
of yourself and your friends get the one
with the best cameras do you want the
one with the longest possible battery
life get the big one but speaking of
battery life I do actually want to
mention that I have noticed I've gotten
better battery life on the iPhone 14
Pros after disabling the always on
display this is something we were
wondering from the review I've had a
couple days or weeks now to do it and
yeah it does make a difference but that
actually leads to the second part of the
video when I wanted to go over a little
bit more which is the state of the
iPhone 14s about a month later so it's
been an interesting couple of weeks
testing these phones and seeing what's
happening to other people with their
phones my reviews went out using the
phone's Apple loans for reviews but then
since then I've gotten my own that I've
bought and started using full-time I
haven't really had any major issues but
it does seem like this has been one of
the notably buggier launches of a new
iOS and iPhone in the past couple years
and even though it's not happening to my
phones it's hard to ignore so there was
a pretty famous camera jittering bug
with the pro iPhones but for a quick iOS
16.0.2 update I ironed that out the only
issue I've personally noticed on mine is
my iPhone 14 pro often takes forever to
connect to wireless car play and often
just fails and doesn't connect but then
again I can't tell if that's just the
new iOS or the Cadillac lyric that's
causing this exact problem but I asked
on Twitter hey how is everyone's iPhone
14 experience is going so far the first
few weeks and of course this is going to
be a pretty focused sample but thousands
and thousands of you chimed in and I've
spent quite a while reading through a
lot of this stuff and it's almost a
little bit surprising how many bugs I've
been getting tweeted about here are the
three most frequent things that I'm
seeing from you guys in my Twitter
Dimension so the first one is lock
screen stuff specifically uh it seems
like there's like an auto rotate bug
when customizing your lock screen tons
of people send me screenshots of it
videos of it it hasn't happened to mine
but it's been annoying because then you
kind of have to reset your phone restart
it and start it again but that's like
the number one thing I saw most
frequently then number two was Dynamic
Island stuff so a lot of people with the
pro phones have noticed weird bugs with
Dynamic Island the software bubble like
moving to the wrong place or animating
weirdly getting stuck in animations
quirky stuff like that I kind of
expected that to happen a little bit at
the beginning but that obviously kind of
breaks the illusion of it just being
this little seamless little pill box of
software that's annoying but then number
three is battery drain and this is the
one I am most concerned about a sort of
alarming number of people just when I
asked about it it's been floating around
there already but people just chiming in
with like yep the battery doesn't last
as long as I expected it doesn't last as
long as a previous phone I had it's been
draining and telling me that it's been
draining and I'll like wake up in the
middle of the night and have like a warm
phone with a nearly dead battery weird
stuff uh so that's the one that I'm
gonna keep my eye on that I think
Apple's probably also going to be paying
the most attention to it's the hardest
one to fix also shout out to channel
sponsor dbrand they just dropped this
new sick digital camo design they call
it glitch camo they've also got a navy
and Arctic colorway available great way
to make your iPhone stand out from the
rest you can check these out at the link
below but there you have it that's the
iPhone 14 plus and the iPhones one month
later
thanks for watching
you guys in the next one peace
[Music]